[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture
bonjour note annie vol zéro vis de vous
dire bonjour et merci on va se dire
merci aujourd'hui on va se dire merci
bonjour patrice brosse des mercis
et bien on va se dire merci parce que
nous recevons aujourd'hui olympia
alberti ou jours bonjour bonjour vous
êtes écrivain vous êtes auteur de
nombreux romans des nouvelles vous êtes
également poète vous êtes essayiste des
essais sur relic sur giono sur colette
également les 100 mots de venise dans la
célèbre collection que sage et vous
venez de publier et bien petit éloge de
la gratitude aux éditions les pérégrine
alors la gratitude pour aller célébrer
depuis longtemps les philosophes grecs y
voyait déjà une vertu elle est au centre
de différentes pratiques spirituelles et
voilà que ce sentiment est remis au goût
du jour
n'est ce pas patrice on ne cesse en ce
début de 21e siècle et bien de
l'invoquer oui mais alors on va
commencer d'abord par le début si je
peux dire c'est toujours mieux par une
anecdote que vous racontez que vous
étiez enfant
l'étape audi chérie avec votre votre
maman et puis vous donner ma maman c'est
ma belle-mère m ont dit chérie j'ai j'ai
21 ans je suis jeune mariée et j'ai
donné un peu d'argent à des lieux à
l'est près particulièrement voilà qu'est
ce que vous dites mais il m'a rien dit
mais même pas dit merci
oui c'était un peu un peu ce que je lui
ai dit et elle m'a dit mais c'est à toi
de le remercier puisqu'il a permis de
faire une bonne action
ah ben c'est une chose qui m'a marqué
pour la vie et qui est resté en moi et
puis et puis ensuite c'est la rencontre
d'un grand spirituelle qui a répondu à
une de mes questions il m'a dit si votre
situation s'arrange
ne soyez pas ingrate et j'ai été
littéralement souffleter par cette
phrase je savais que ma substance prix
devenir celle drina gratte m'a
profondément secoué et à partir de là je
me suis mise à pratiquer la gratitude à
tout bout de champ alors délire c'est
très intéressant parce que vous
vous racontez nous vient ce mot
gratitude du moyen-âge mais à l'époque
ça vient de la technique un gr
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas de nya pas de
audi pas grave on dit gratitude mais on
n'y a pas de l'affectif qui correspond à
un gramme et donc on serait passé d'une
certaine façon du négatif pour aller
vers le vers le positif
1 la gratitude
comment la définir il faut quand même la
définir parce que comment la distingue
par exemple de la bienveillance de la
gentillesse de l'altruisme
moi je pense que la gratitude c'est
d'abord l'attitude intérieur de
quelqu'un qui se sent gratifié par
quelqu'un d'autre
donc ça suppose que l'on fasse attention
à autrui et que si l'autre à côté de
nous en face de nous fait un geste pour
nous on l'en remercie
je commence par ce vous avez pu
constater que dans mon petit essai je
vais par étapes très doucement et je
commence par quelque chose qui accueille
l'espace de l'autre
premièrement quand ils s'adressent à
nous et puis peut un peu on va aller
jusqu à être habitée par quelque chose
de deux heureux de lumineux qui est de
se rendre compte que non seulement on
n'est pas seul mais qu' il y à une sorte
justement de bienveillance qui est
alentours de nous et qui nous permet
d'avoir une relation au monde qui est
beaucoup plus lumineuse beaucoup plus
ouverte c'est beaucoup plus généreuse
aussi par les mêmes de contagion à vous
dites c'est contagieux
oui j'ai remarqué que dans la vie
d'ailleurs quand on est positif on
oppose un refus aux énergies négatives
qui nous entoure est hélas les français
on est très doué pour ça on est des
râleurs invétérés
ça peut être bien d'être un râleur parce
que on n'exige plus mais il faut d'abord
exigé de soi même je pense que si on
exige beaucoup de soi-même on arrive à
quelque chose de passionnant qui est de
se rendre compte que on n'en fait pas
assez pour les autres on n'est pas assez
à l'écouté de tout ce que l'on peut
faire de bons et justement alors au
centre de votre livre il ya il ya la
question de la frustration
et celle de la jalousie vous écrivez ne
pas passer sa vie dans le désir
permanent permet de rejoindre une
gratitude fondatrice se satisfaire de
peu est une grande richesse alors en
théorie oui cela paraît formidable mais
quand on est malheureux est-ce qu'il
suffit de se dire qu'on est en bonne
santé
qu'on vit dans un pays sans guerre et
puis pour le manger à notre faim
en quoi la gratitude et l rempart
efficace en à nos passions tristes parce
que au départ si vous partez du principe
que ce qui vous arrive est bon ce qui
est vous arrivez formateur à partir de
ce moment là tout ce que vous allez
faire va aller dans un bon sens non pas
le simple bon sens mais un bon sens
c'est-à-dire on se sent gratifié par la
moindre chose c'est vrai que quand on
est malheureux il faut s'adresser à une
énergie supérieure qu'on l'appelle dieu
le monde l'univers qu'on donne le nom
que l'on veut à ce genre de choses ça
n'a pas d'importance
ce qui est important c'est de se dire
que ce qui m'arrive c'est pour m'aider à
devenir meilleur c'est pour m'aider à
aller plus loin à l'intérieur de moi
même et comprendre que ce qui est
apparemment un malheur n'est peut-être
un malheur que temporel c'est l'anecdote
soufi à un moment de ce vieux maître en
afghanistan vous savez que j'ai racontée
vous pouvez peut-être le dire ou alors
c'est l'histoire de ce jeune homme qui
gagne un cheval à une loterie du village
et les villageois pour voir le son père
qui est un grand maître et lui disent
bonheur tant pis ça gagne à cheval et il
répond qu'il vous dit que c'est un
bonheur alors ils partent en disant
bahamas alors nous on paye est un
bonheur de gagner à cheval et puis le
lendemain il tombe du cheval il se casse
une jambe parce qu'il a montée accrue
alors ils vont voir le maître tu avais
raison grand maître tout c'était un
malheur finalement il dit il aurait bon
qui vous dit que c'est un malheur et le
surlendemain la contrée où ils habitent
entre en guerre avec une autre contrée
et celui qui s'est cassé la jambe ne va
pas avec nous jusqu'au pas se précipiter
pour interpréter justement alors
ce que vous dites là savez ce que vous
écrivez ça pose une question quelle est
la différence parce que c'est une c'est
une grave titude spirituel mais qui
n'est pas religieuse parce que les gens
qui croient les gens qui croient peuvent
avoir aussi ce même genre de sentiments
c'est à dire que le bas le malheur c'est
quelque chose que dieu leur a envoyé
pour les rendre meilleurs
il ya aussi dans les religions mais là
je vous souhaite une 7ème gratuite sans
la religion ainsi je peux dire ces
solutions moi je pense j'ai souvent une
formule l'intérieur qui secoue les amis
je dis dieu et laïque
c'est nous qui faisons de l'espace
religieux un carcan un lieu de défiance
de l'authie tu n'es pas comment as tu es
contre moi et c'est la spiritualité
c'est déjà autre chose et plus ouverts
c'est plus lumineux etc plus partageur
ça ne crée pas des barrières sacré au
contraire une unité ce qui est bon c'est
de se tenir au difficile 10 et rilke et
c'est ce qu'il nous apporte où on peut
tomber aussi dans une formule que je
trouve très chouette de nietzsche qui
dit vouloir libère c'est à dire vouloir
devenir meilleur
c'est une chance c'est une chose de
s'appliquer à soi-même des devoirs de
beauté se dire bah la petite fleur quand
il pleut qu'il vente qu'il neige elle
essaie de faire son effort de beauté bas
faisons pareil essayons de devenir
meilleur parce qu'en fait on doit
s'interroger sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
notre vie est ce que la vie n'est pas le
lieu de l'exercice pour aller vers plus
de compréhension plus de justesse plus
de sagesse plus d'amour et la gratitude
qui au départ est un sentiment devient
très vite mise en pratique une sorte de
vertu et alors justement vous proposez
vous avez parlé de devoir envers
soi-même vous proposer à la fin de
chaque chapitre des exercices à
pratiquer au quotidien par exemple
donner chaque jour quelque chose à
quelqu'un ou encore envoyer une lettre à
une personne que l'on n'a pas remercié
pour un bienfait faire le bilan du
positif et du négatif à la fin d'une
journée
vous pensez que la quête du bonheur ça
s'apprend qu'on peut travailler sur soi
pour être plus heureux
pour être plus épanouie oui je suis
persuadé que
ce qui est de l'ordre du positif dans
notre vie doit se mériter doit se
travailler
il y à ce avec quoi on arrive sur terre
les acquis les lésiné on devrait dire et
puis ce qui va ce hacker vire le dans un
moment de ma vie j'ai je m'estimais je
me mets prouver comme malheureuse et
puis un jour ni très grande amie qui m'a
été très proche qui n'est plus de ce
monde m'a dit tu sais le bonheur c'est
sont des petites choses qu'il faut
savoir que yi he et ce sont des choses
infime pour lesquelles tu va peu à peu
éprouvé de la gratitude
c'est de savoir se ménager un espace un
moment de méditation de la lecture
allez marcher pendant un quart d'heure
vingt minutes qui pleuve qu'il vente ou
qu'il neige peu importe on s'habille et
puis on va marcher et on est au contact
avec le monde alors bien sûr dans cette
période de tensions et de difficultés
sanitaires on n'a pas toujours eu
l'occasion de défaite eux d'aller se
promener comme on en aurait eu envie ou
alors dans un espace très limité mais
peu importe je pense que la contrainte a
aussi à nous apprendre
le difficile le rugueux ont quelque
chose à nous apprendre qui nous rend
meilleurs plus attentifs à l'essentiel
la survie puisque puisque vous parlez de
cette situation actuelle la le coc
finement la maladie le virus on peut
avoir de la gratitude vis-à-vis du virus
c'est une c'est un exercice mental très
difficile mais regardez pour certains
enfin j'en suis cette épreuve 100 et une
puisque on perd des gens qu'on aime
parce qu'on est on est accablé de voir
ce qui arrive aux autres
tant qu'on est vivant c'est en même
temps un moment de réflexion qui nous
est demandé qu'est ce que nous avions
dont nous n'avions pas conscience la
liberté de faire tout ce que nous
voulions de sortir de rencontrer les
gens et c'est d'aller au théâtre au
cinéma l'opéra de se rencontrer avec des
amis de donner un dîner tout ça c'est
fini mais
peut-être qu'il faut que nous prenions
conscience que nous avions beaucoup et
que justement nous étions très ingrat
avec ce beau coup il a un sacré tour de
vis nous est donné c'est sûr c'est vrai
qu'une grande aspiration pour ce qu'on
appelle dans un terme générique la
psychologie positive
et puis il ya quand même des gens qui
tique qui conteste sa par exemple des
gens qui disent bon aspirer au bonheur
c'est très bien mais on sait très bien
ce qui le malheur le bonheur c'est plus
difficile à définir et de la même phase
on pourrait dire ben la gratitude on
voit la gratitude c'est déjà plus
compliqué à définir ça c'est une
première critique quand vous qu'on
préfère bien sûr mais je pense que
choisir la gratitude c'est choisir
quelque chose de difficile
c'est choisir quelque chose qui va nous
imposer de faire des efforts c'est
choisir une voie beaucoup plus ardu
qu'il me semble et qui va nous pousser
vers la persévérance et pour ma part
jeunesse je ne sais pas donné de réponse
juste quelques petits exemples quelques
petites commandes ird et des partages
d'expérience vous savez j'encourage
toujours j'encourage mes étudiants quand
j'enseignais l'université je leur disais
ne me croyez pas sur parole
faites l'expérience et vous verrez si
c'est bon ou si c'est mauvais et j'ai
tendance à chérir justement l'expérience
et la persévérance plutôt que le comble
immédiat du désir
peut-être que il faut faire monter cette
grâce de l'énergie cette grâce du combat
intérieur pour changer de regard un
moment d'ailleurs j'ai un chapitre où je
parle de chou de changer de regard et
ont du coup une épreuve est une chose
qui peut sembler difficile s'avéra
quelque temps après une chose
extraordinairement positive donc c'est
notre façon de voir les choses qui fait
aussi le malheur mais là est ce que est
ce que quand même à force de vouloir le
bonheur l'épanouissement comme ça on est
contraint de refuser la douleur est ce
qu'on voit pas aussi refusé d'évacuer
cette douleur qui est omniprésente qui
qu'on a besoin aussi pour affronter le
devons à besoin pardon aussi pour
affronter le monde
on a besoin de quoi de d'exprimer de la
douleur oui tout à fait de ne pas la
refuser ce qu'on peut dire les choses si
par hasard faisait attention moi la
gratitude pour moi j'ai expérimenté
qu'elle rendait plus heureuse mais mais
c'est aussi avec un environnement de
d'autres qualités la générosité et
l'altruisme l'écoutent la sensibilité
que l'on laisse vivre et donc au
contraire il faut l'accepter vous savez
ya il ya l'honneur de souffrir d'un has
no hay et puis ce mode mère teresa qui
m'a toujours beaucoup frappée elle dit
le malheur de l'occident c'est que vous
ne savez pas souffrir
on a été habitué à un monde d'abondance
des publicités c'est ça la quête du
bonheur
moi je ne pour moi le bonheur c'est pas
le problème le ce que je trouve plus
intéressant c'est la joie et la joie
parfois les douloureuses et les brûlants
tels fait pleurer mais je suis persuadé
que ce qui compte c'est de se sentir et
s'est prouvé devenir meilleurs et plus
attentif aux autres
la quête du bonheur c'est c'est celle
d'une civilisation occidentale qui a
évacué justement la souffrance la
difficulté la mort non non
ces choses là existe et peut vivre avec
et bien les pieds alberti on va on va
vous remercier avec beaucoup de
gratitude parce que c'est évident à voir
un livre un livre qui fait beaucoup de
bien ça s'appelle petit éloge de la
gratitude et c'est aux éditions les
pérégrine olympia alberti merci d'un tel
vol merci merci merci merci patrice
merci à vous
[Musique]